nice conversion this time for from joe
crush
should be here as well oh my god he's
not dead right oh my god big boy
god the combo
four
and i think that makes down four two
even stronger the fact that you know
brian has to play that way big damage
here on top of it oh my god and the
balcony boy
kicks
recognize he wasn't getting the second
hit there look at this he's all caught
up oh my god
that was a nice lead you had there kid
you see how ugly my outfit is you think
i care
you think i care soccer kicks from big
change oh that was sick
oh my god joyce
oh
dude that low parry was so late that
slide was like hitting i swear it hit
one of his legs like nothing i don't pay
the other leg
[Music]
all right all right two
to the next one he doesn't get the
extension
oh he's gonna have to be careful the
whip right there he's gonna have one two
two rage won't
junior pdx one
the mix not enough damage on the pixel
yeah joey time winding down avoid the
arrow puking
rage is good the tackle broken
five seconds
joey no time too far enough wait a
second that might work he's gonna hit
him joey fury
joe cruz went for the ground grab
unnecessarily it whiffs so he finds the
range number one second and falls give
me the round
trying to get onto the winner's side of
the bracket it's never over till it's
over that was crazy